[Music]
as chess players we've had a symbiotic
relationship with computers for quite a
long time are you using the new
technology chat GPT all these new
artificial intelligence solutions that
we have right now
here we're just players use AI to change
I think it's an open Secrets yes and
neural network is basically a must for
today's ground Master it was Revolution
like some five years ago I think that
Alpha zero bits
back then in London that was very
unexpected and very big chance engine is
like I got I mean it cannot be beaten
and here it comes some AI you know who a
day before didn't know which is rules
and just smashed smashed the stockfish
so after that I mean
everyone was really like
fascinated I guess by it and also was
looking for ways to improve their chess
yeah I mean for me personally like Alpha
zero and and just AI stuff is um as a
whole is of course it changed the game
of just the way we played compared to a
few years ago when it came but I believe
it's just sort of a test phrase if you
build a company version of what's going
to happen outside of Chess in the real
world and I believe since chess is you
know to me it's a very important game
but it's just a game right there are
much more serious issues in the world so
I believe chess is showing the day I can
come up with
serious unexplored ideas in a game that
people have been playing for for you
know ages AI can really be a game
changer it's still progressing a lot we
don't know after one or two year what
will happen but I'm sure that if we can
use it in a good way it can be
beneficial for chess and as it was for
instance a stockfish when it came out
everybody thought it would be dead the
chest but it also grow the chest so we
can learn more and we study more but I'm
very optimistic chess and AI together
it's a very good combination computer
Thriller revolutionized the game
um so players as a player you need to
adjust be ready for
uh everything but at the same time I
think that computers can only really do
so much in the game because
as a player you can your brain can only
take so much you can only memorize so
many lines
so in that regarding chess has become
more difficult than the old days I
personally in my opinion I don't think
that the computer can change the game as
radical some people think it can but
I think young people still play the game
there's obviously a lot more Theory
nowadays than before yeah the AI has
sort of
I started with chess pretty much
I think the big breakthrough was when
Alpha zero
was built and that that's also you know
gave confidence to our researchers
as I've heard to to you know to see the
potential and now building on that there
are so many tools already in the making
and I'm sure within the chess within the
Chess World there are many things you
can utilize it for you can definitely
see um
potential in some sort of AI tutoring it
seems like it's liking you know power to
answer these specific questions and
for now and it seems like you know the
engines we have no stockfish with Alpha
zero when they when it came out they're
the best AIS that I know to answer these
specific questions so foreign
professionals and I suspect it won't be
anytime soon but I could be wrong yeah I
think I will try that
sometimes it wasn't they will combine
Maybe
zero or something yeah and it would be
quite quite useful too but I guess we
are not at this point but you know
things are developing quickly
itself like we don't
like the language learning model doesn't
have
much relevance at the moment for chess
but still like we've seen the the
computer Revolution it continues like
computers are super super strong in
chess and and I think that we're going
to see that like across the board not
just in chess but in everyday life
technology is going to continue to uh to
to
expand and
who knows what will happen I mean
hopefully more good things and bad
things well you never know but in terms
of Chess it's definitely changed the
game quite a lot
thank you